ich bin in berlin
das kannst du nicht sein
rebecca mir meine gute youtube freundin
hat mir mit ihren videos schon die ein
oder andere saftige steilvorlage für ein
video für sie gegeben
mit diesem ganzen gamers da sind wo man
sich als normal denkender und die welt
begreifen der mensch fast schon äußern
muss sagt ok letztlich als die sache
ruhen weil wegen wird videos sind auch
schon ein oder zwei monate her aber dann
habe ich von einem zuschauern hinweis
darauf bekommen
das ist doch ein spezielles video gibt
dass ich mir vielleicht noch mal
anschauen sollte bevor ich selbst die
hoffnung in wedding vollends aufgehen
wird und zwar in berlin vor einem
monaten video hochgeladen hat eine
million klicks kämpfen alleine gegen
game master im wald wer ist besser und
auf dem empfang nail sieht man wie sie
den game master tritt ok denke ich wir
schauen uns dieses wunderbar wie heute
an und prüfen die realitätsgetreue die
ganze handlung dieses besonderen videos
ist und natürlich wollen wir auch alle
wissen wer den kampf gewinnt ich bin
jetzt in dem park neben der game master
glaube ich meinte das ist ja derselbe wo
er schon mal ein teil der karte
hinterlassen hat das muss man sich auch
erst mal geben heute wir müssen mal
diese gesamte idee dieses videos auf uns
wirken lassen ganz ehrlich dieses ganze
game master zeigt das ist doch
mittlerweile ein einziger drogentrip
oder ich hab das gefühl das ist so als
hätte irgendjemand wenn ich mir die
ganzen videos von der bäckerei dazu
ansehen dann sieht es für mich so aus
als hätte jemand irgendwelche
geisteskranken psychoaktiven substanzen
genommen aber halt für monate
durchgehend und ist permanent voll auf
droge und kommt dann damit mit solchen
ideen herum wie es sind dass man als
zierliches mädchen gegen den game master
kämpft ich mache was ist das also ich
werde jetzt erstmal hier hoch laufen
dann kommt man da hinten zum
fußballplatz dann zu so einem teich
meine ich komme immer noch nicht drauf
klar leute wie kommt man auf so was kann
welche drogen nimmst du weißt was ist
das pilze ist es lsd crack
ansonsten weiß nicht ob ich da hoch
laufen soll
vielleicht gucken einen stunden bis man
da vielleicht eine kamera nach abba oder
vielleicht weil du vorhast gegen eine
fiktive personen zu kämpfen
die wir selbst ausgedachtes nein warte
die wir nicht mal selbst ausgedacht hat
sondern die in einem trend in amerika
ausgedacht wurde dass an diesen trend
übernommen in deutschland und jetzt hast
du irgendein kumpel von mir genommen und
in game master kostüm gesteckt
dann käme es jetzt gegen den nicht
unbedingt die klügste entscheidung ja
ich weiß ich hab dir mit dem game master
elbracht zu tun haben ja doch ich glaube
auf jeden fall die leute in diesem park
dies selbst empfinden dass da wie so
eine junge dame ist die sich selbst eine
kamera ins gesicht hält und mit der
kamera redet die werden im servicefall
alle mit dem game master was zu tun
haben auf jeden fall besser was auch
immer du nimmst ist tut dir nicht ganz
so gut lief habe ich keine ahnung und
nachrichten sollten nichts konkret
geschrieben ja nichts weiter hinten lief
kati und knuspriger also was auch die
vorgeschichte dazu also ich hoffe leute
ihr verzeiht mir dass es mir nicht alle
videos davor angeschaut habe aber also
selbst erst mal rein versetzen und so
tun als wir das irgendwie was was
tatsächlich passieren könnte es ist
natürlich absoluter unsinn wir wissen
jetzt alle es ist eine ausgedachte figur
in dem kostüm steckt ihren kumpel von
rebecca aber sie hat sich ja okay du
mich so als würde ich gegen kämpfen
bringt millionen klicks alles klar aber
was man da rein versetzen
mal angenommen es gibt wirklich so eine
eine person so eine mysteriöse fremde
personen die die ihr scheinbar schaden
will
welches mädchen kanada anfang mitte 20
denkt sich dann so dass ein fremder mann
ich habe keine ahnung welche statur der
hat wie starte es wie gefährlich ist
ich kämpfe gegen den ein weiterer beweis
dafür dass rebecca ding einfach vollends
lost auf lsd ist
hier
irgendwas was irgendwie verdächtig
aussieht moment mal was hat diese
tischtennisplatte mit dem game master zu
tun wurde diese tischtennisplatte
möglicherweise vom game master selbst
beauftragt an diesem ort und an dieser
stelle zu sein
schauen wir uns mal genauer an ja doch
ich glaube die die töchter des paters im
game master zu tun genau wie die leute
im park schon einen jogger unterwegs
das ist doch nicht mehr normal oder ist
das zufall leute es glaube ich
[Applaus]
die armen leute diese partner ohne
sitzung schon mal vorher geht einfach so
ein park soll hier dreht runden
geschockt hat gerade so 1 platz die
lunge okay geht gas und dann ist ja so
eine tante mit der kamera filmt euch und
fragt sich lautstark ob ihr der game
master seit der kann ich mal hier in
ruhe sport machen an diesem chelsea
can't fucking game macht euch job hier
einfach nur okay kommt von eintrifft und
fußball so verdächtig sieht man jetzt
nicht aus da der ernst fübbeker re sieht
sich durchaus als wenn der fußballplatz
nichts mit dem game master zu tun hat
und weil sie auch nicht kölns verstehen
leute also ganz ehrlich schauen wir mal
kurz auf diesen fußballplatz man sieht
doch sofort dass der was mit dem game
master zu tun hat rebecca was ist mit
dir habe ich dann nur zeitverschwendung
nicht okay dass sie sich jetzt nicht die
frage stellt was die pflastersteine auf
denen sie läuft mit dem game master zu
tun haben das wundert mich ein bisschen
aber ohne wird sollte man muss auch
rebecca wen auch immer ein kompliment
geben wir jetzt drei minuten 26 von
diesem video gesehen und aus irgendeinem
grund schafft sie ist einfach durch den
park zu laufen sie läuft wirklich
einfach durch den park ist ein
öffentlicher park ich glaube in hamburg
1 in hamburg trade ist es in hamburg
es ist irgend ein öffentlicher park und
sie läuft erfährt durch diesen park und
beschreibt einfach was da ist so hier
ist ein baum hier ist ein fußballplatz
sind die schnelles platte und es ist
schon ein bisschen spannend vielleicht
ist es die musik im hintergrund aber an
der stelle muss man auf jeden fall
weggeschaut dafür geben dass sie einfach
wirklich und einfach nur rum läuft dinge
sieht und beschreibt und man denkt sich
so krass damit hat der game master zu
tun auf jeden fall beschädigt so einiges
an mühlen rom
aber hatte
dahinter ist eine schwarz gekleidete
person jetzt geht's ab jetzt gibt es mal
ganz ehrlich können wir wenn sie der
nächste boxkampf von so logan paul
kommen können wir so eine andere karte
machen beck hoch gingen game master
selber vor so schirmbeck und so ihr
kumpel lot wie auch immer das ist mir
game master kostüm kämpfe einfach so in
den boxring dann ganz ehrlich dann
schauen wir einfach mal wer wem aufs
maul haut und dann dann lassen wir die
sache mal gut sein okay youtube hat
genug davon abbekommen mittlerweile
rebecca mir bernhard wiedergeben oder
was ja das ist das was sich deutschlands
jugend heutzutage anschlag hatte ein
mann in einem schwarzen outfit mit maske
hat irgendwie ein kuscheltier in diesem
blauen tüte was haben wir allerdings war
entführt klar und jetzt stehen sich
gegenüber und ja gleich gehts ab
ich habe gekämpft ist das dein ernst
es kann es doch nicht sein oder also ich
habe schon viel gesehen bei weg bringen
aber es kann es doch einfach nicht sein
also selbst wenn ich neun jahre alt bin
und wickie ist das größte für mich also
man muss doch checken dass so was nicht
echt ist oder auch hier so sie hat
einfach die kamera doch mal hingelegt
die kamera liegt so einen meter von ihm
wirklich gegen sie kämpfen wollen würde
warum sollte man sagen so ok weiß was
wir kämpfen jetzt um das kuscheltier was
ich dir auf jeden fall geklaut habe ok
ich werde bock die auswahl zu bauen legt
aber ruhig vorher noch mal die kamera ab
okay wir sind ja auf youtube ja also
nach youtube regelt alles muss gefilmt
werden blickt die kamera ruhig hin
das kann es doch nicht sein man das kann
es doch nicht sein alter ja ganz ehrlich
wer will schon zweimal schauer gegeben
darüber gering ein drittes schau dort
ist völlig dafür dass sie in dieser
szene ernst geblieben ist hopps alter
das ist ein echtes youtube-video das ist
ein echtes youtube video mit einer
million klicks 42.000 likes und nur 3100
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
also ich halte fest bevor sie ab geht
sowas kann sich wirklich niemand
ausdenken der nicht auf drogen ist
jemand der in vollem bewusstsein ist
geistig gesund ist kommt nicht auf so
was
okay da was da war
sie musste selbst über sich lachen leute
da war es ist das der beweis dafür dass
rebecca wing tatsächlich noch einen
funken selbstkritik im körper hat
achtung achtet auf ihr gesicht da sie
hat gedacht endlich danke danke becker
ja
legende dicker
kein kampf da kamen von becker die uci
ist bereit für dich lieb sie ist bereit
für dich koller mcgregor kann einpacken
der seine karriere schon beendet
wahrscheinlich weil der schlüssel dass
du news sie kommt europas
kampfsportlerin 2009/10 auf jeden fall
lübecker ring also ich muss sagen es war
eine positive überraschung für mich zu
sehen dass man bei karen scheinbar doch
irgendwo ganz hinten in dem hirn noch
merken was sich da gerade macht machen
wir selbst über sich lachen muss das war
viermal positiv ansonsten ist es
natürlich wie immer so einfach
geisteskranke zeug voll drogen modus in
diesem sinne leute hoffe ich dass wir
nicht so sehr verblödet wurde durch
dieses video hier drüben gibt es ein für
euch vorgeschlagen das video auf vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und das gemeinsame
bekkering auslachen
bis zum nächsten video